on
bonjour et bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro de check up dans quelques
instants on va parler médecine avec
notre invité olivier dubourg c'est le
doyen de l'ufr des sciences de la santé
implanté ici à montigny mais d'abord je
vous propose le sommaire c'est la
première rentrée pour les étudiants de
cette ufr de sciences et nous avons
recueilli leurs impressions
et puis nous sommes allés à la maternité
de poissy qui a connu une certaine
célébrité vous verrez cela dans quelques
instants olivier dubourg bonjour
franchement merci d'être l'invité de
check up le premier delà de la saison
vous êtes doyen de l'ufr des sciences de
la santé implanté ici à montigny il ya
quelques jours les étudiants de première
année ont fait leur première rentrée ils
étaient 1 856 comment s'est passée cette
rentrée pour vous et pour les étudiants
pour moi très bien pour les étudiants je
pense aussi pas fait correctement à
l'ufr des sciences de la santé ici à mon
tennis est pas vraiment une création
propre c'est un regroupement d'entités
qui était déjà existantes oui vous avez
raison mais enfin là c'est quand même le
nom et les structures
d'ailleurs le nom lui-même vous avez
fait attention à bien dire que c'est une
ufr des sciences de la santé c'est vrai
pas c'est à dire que c'est normalement
aussi une ufr de médecine
en fait 80 % des étudiants qui sont sur
les rangs gros 900 inscrits front aux
médecines douces on voulait faire
médecine et bien sûr ils font pour
médecine à cause la sélection qu'il y
aura l'arrivée mais
d autres professions de santé font
partie intégrante et s'exposent ce
pourquoi ça s'appelle pas été de
formation et je dis qu'il ya combien de
disciplines enseignées et faites nous
l'avait dit une filière médicale et une
filière mais paramédical aussi ici c'est
pas seulement paramédical c'est vraiment
les professions de santé ces volets qui
sont autour paramédical c'est encore un
peu en plus si vous voulez les quatre
filières c'est à dire les quatre
concours qui vont qui vont être là sic
maintenant dans cette réforme des études
médicales si vous aurez la médecine qui
représente sur à la fin du cursus de la
première année sur les 900 qui sont
inscrits à peu près 100 110 étudiants
vous aurez la pharmacie donc c'est le
deuxième concours à peu près une
quarantaine d'étudiants vous aurez nos
motos logis qui vont avoir à peu près 15
étudiants et vous aurez
des sages femmes qui vont représenter
encore une carte d'un étudiant donc si
vous voulez c'est cet ensemble de quatre
professions de santé qui vont être
qu'ils vont passer quatre concours et
puis après vous aurez d'autres
possibilités ccsa l'organisation pour
pas perdre
les tous les étudiants qui ont passé
cette année à travailler c'est au volet
ceux qui ont réussi mais qui rompt pas
le numerus clausus donc ils sont pas
réussi au concours seront appelés
rédecoller qui ont réussi voulait coller
reçues il faut leur donner une
orientation est donc là encore on peut
les réorienter vers différentes
professions ça peut être manille prades
you ergothérapeute kinésie
infirmiers envoyez donc c'est pour part
peut être toute sa sucette substratum de
gens qui voulaient s'intéresser à la
santé et puis il ya encore d'autres
filières qui seront des passerelles qui
pour ne pour que les étudiants ne
perdent pas leur temps s'ils voulaient
qu'ils perdent pas cette première année
d'études ils peuvent aller par exemple
valu à faire des sciences ou d'autres
professions qui sont proches de la nôtre
et donc c'est vraiment une réforme
intelligente en tant que tel c'est vrai
mais il faut pas croire que les 900
étudiants qui sont inscrits ici vont
tous faire médecine non non on n'en
parlera plus justement de ce fameux
numerus clausus est est ce que vous en
pensez mais au niveau des disciplines
qui sont enseignées si ce qu'il ya des
particularités est ce qu'il y aura une
couleur
d'enseignement ici est ce qu'il y avait
c'est à dire qu'il ya une couleur sur la
recherche qui va être fait dans la
faculté plutôt sur
l'environnement leur handicap
voyez un petit peu l'épidémiologie donc
ça va être les éléments forts autour
laquelle la fac s'est structuré où il y
aura de la recherche ici ayant beaucoup
aussi de biologie va faire une première
peau si vous permettez on est allé
justement sur cette première journée de
rentrée ici alu fr et on a été rencontré
des étudiants d'été recueillir leurs
impressions on les écoute
l'université de saint quentin en
yvelines se développe sorti de terre
près du centre commercial skywest un
nouveau bâtiment accueille désormais les
étudiants de l'ufr des sciences de la
santé communément appelée fac de
médecine les jeunes ont découvert leurs
locaux flambant neufs lors de la rentrée
parce que vous savez que la sarre
nouveau bâti well as tu es quand cette
année sa
rentrée non jamais c'est la première
qu'est ce que vous en attendez de ce
bâti bail doit il doit être bien
doit être moderne et moderne c'est
toujours mieux il ya moins de problèmes
techniques c'est peut-être mieux pour
apprendre aussi
moi je n'aime pas trop ce
que c'est bien mais on a pris nos
repères c'est pas nous
romero
non non c'est quand même pas ce matin
856 étudiants de première année ont
réalisé leur rentrée accueilli par le
vice doyen ce qui change c'est d'abord
et avant tout d'avoir un bâtiment
moderne
construit selon les normes hqe club et
surtout avec un équipement informatique
et numérique tout à fait adaptée aux
défis modernes de l'enseignement avec
des tableaux interactifs
de quoi rassurer les premières années
qui devront se partager le mans de 200
places en filières médicales et
paramédicales
alors de retour sur le plateau avec vos
olivier dubourg donc doyen de l'ufr des
sciences de la santé à montigny on voit
que les étudiants sont assez content
d'être ici vous nous expliquer un petit
peu comment fonctionner ici une fac des
sciences et on est là pour apprendre il
ya des laboratoires et puis aussi il ya
des hauts des hôpitaux associer des
laboratoires de recherche associés c'est
exactement c'est parce que pas pardon un
seul bâtiment qui est ici à montigny le
leur cursus il va être la façon suivante
il ya des parties théoriques avec des t
d si vous voulez et il va y avoir la
première année deux parties ces deux
partis vont leur donner quatre concours
puisque je vous ai dit qu'il y avait
quatre filières médecine pharmacie
odontologie et sages-femmes et puis
on va donc avoir par exemple une
ventilation avec
un ordre qui va être donnée à chacun il
va avoir un rang qui va leur permettre
de savoir s'ils continuent dans une
filière donc il ya une deuxième concours
qui est fait avec une série encore de
quatre filières et donc la fin de cette
année là les gens savent s'ils vont
aller dans groupe médical groupe e parce
que problématique en fait des facultés
de médecine c'est maintenant vous l'avez
dit le taux d'échec aux
rites d'une faculté à l'autre entre neuf
et 24% ce qu'il veut tellement c'est
exactement ça donc il y avait une perte
avec des gens excessivement intelligents
aux travailleurs ou des gens motivés
donc après c'est pas exactement la vraie
perte sur une année parce que certains
vont avoir le droit de redoubler mais on
donne le droit de redoubler
400 premiers contres qu'on était collé
vous comprenez c'est après il ya le
fameux numerus clausus dont vous avez
parlé qui est en fait le nombre
d'étudiants admis en deuxième année
exactement donc il est de 191
il faut il faut pas lever 160 et on a
tous nos problèmes et si on a une fac
avec des dimensions ses volets des
enseignants des salles des salles de td
un personnel administratif qui est
adapté à une certaine dimension c'est la
même chose que si vous imaginiez je sais
pas 1 restant avec un nombre de tables
vous pouvez pas imaginer augmenté
augmentaient augmenté c'est pas possible
et d'ailleurs cette année dans certaines
facultés nous on a augmenté notre taux
par rapport à l'année dernière dans
certaines facultés parisiennes mes
collègues ne rien rapporter 25 %
d'augmentation on touche pas au numerus
clausus on laisse tel quel mais par
contre effectivement on fait en sorte
que l'orientation à la fin de la
première année soit différente offrent
des passerelles par cette seule puce
stratton et on ose dire à des gens qui
voudraient faire médecine pourquoi vous
ne feriez pas une autre profession
proche de la profession médicale et même
ça peut se dérider à l'extrême si vous
voulez et est allé depuis je vous dis
médecins sages femmes pharmaciens vers
kinés infirmières et c'est vraiment
déchiré des métiers dont on a besoin
dans la santé vous le savez ça c'est
vraiment un truc essentiel et puisque
vous parlez de métier dont on a besoin
sans toi aussi besoin de médecins
beaucoup on parle des déserts médicaux
ici à 50 ans on parle de trappes et la
verrière comme des villes ou
potentiellement il pourrait manquer le
médecin est ce que le fait qu'ici votre
faculté sont implantés au coeur d'une
ville est ce que du coup ou répondu
aussi un peu à ces problèmes politiques
c'était des arguments pour ouvrir une
faculté en dehors d'hôpitaux puisqu'il
n'ya pas un hôpital juste à côté donc
c'est une force je vous le dis qu'on est
différents hôpitaux qui vont ils enfin
c'est une difficulté pour les étudiants
eux mêmes donc ça c'est vrai il dit mais
toujours est il que là ils sont
regroupés sur la partie la plus
studieuse je dirais et donc
oui c'est un élément qu'on a en tout cas
fait valoir de dire qu'on formait des
gens qui seront probablement des gens
qui formaient une situe pour on
s'installe et in situ c'est très
probablement vrai pour des professions
par exemple les sages-femmes qui va
avoir une école ici on peut espérer que
la partie non pas sur la côte d'azur par
exemple on va aller à cette fois au
service de maternité de l'hôpital de
poissy un des hôpitaux partenaires de
l'ue fr et c'est tant pis y'a qu'a été
mis en lumière par la télé réalité ont
regardé ce reportage
lohan aurait pu participer au programme
baby boom ce petit tiny montain d'à
peine une heure est né à la maternité de
poissy c'est dans ce service que les
caméras de tf1 se sont installés pendant
un mois pour filmer la deuxième saison
de baby boom un programme à mi chemin
entre documentaire et télé-réalité la
caméra son suffixe en va des sondes
installées en avance dans le service ce
qui fait qu'on n'a jamais aucun
caméraman en visu donc ça que c'est une
technique a priori
qui est utilisé beaucoup dans la télé
réalité mais qui permet essentiellement
là dans l'hôpital d'être complètement
seul avec les patients c'est linguae
sage femme à l'hôpital de poissy depuis
cinq ans elle a participé à la première
saison de baby boom suivi par 2 millions
et demi de téléspectateurs
on n'avait jamais vu le travail de
sages-femmes de cette façon là ça
permettait de voir bas que quand même
pas que l'accouchement il y avait aussi
tout l'encadrement des couples je crois
que cette première saison elle était
bien aussi parce qu'elle permettait de
voir ce qui se passe dans une salle de
naissance quand on n'y est pas non
professionnels de santé ce qui se passe
entre le père la mère et puis après les
avec le bébé et que c'était au plus
proche vous fait de l'émotion vraiment
ressenti par les gens 50 caméras
dissimulées en salle d'accouchement aux
urgences ou encore en réanimation des
nouveau nés pour suivre au plus près la
couche man 2 65 maman et le travail
d'une dizaine de sages femmes on a donc
des patientes qui nous sont attribués à
chacune chacune a ses patientes et puis
on suit le travail en cours de chaque de
chaque dame ont fait les accouchements
on récupère le bébé des césariennes
programmées
on s'occupe des enfants qui sont nommés
et des patientes en fonction des
différentes façons d'accoucher sur les
65 femmes volontaires seuls ne
figureront dans le programme dont
l'intégralité des épisodes a été
visionné par françoise damageux très
impliqué depuis la première saison que
ce soit dans la première saison où dans
la deuxième on avait un droit de regard
c'est à dire qu'on était deux personnes
moi même et un des médecins de l'équipe
où nous avons visionné l'ensemble des
épisodes nous avions uniquement un droit
de regard sur le niveau déontologique
secret médical céline elle n'a pas
encore visionné la nouvelle saison de
baby boom premier épisode sur tf1 mardi
18 septembre à 23h15
merci olivier dubourg d'avoir répondu à
nos questions c'est fini pour ce premier
numéro de check up de la saison prochain
rendez vous dans un mois d'ici là portez
vous bien
à